Mila Kunis reveals she and husband
Ashton Kutcher have already taught their
one-year-old daughter about beer but
don't worry it's totally adorable it's
really cute kids say the darndest things
but in this case blame Ashton Kutcher
his wife bad mom star Mila Kunis was a
guest on wednesday's Tonight Show where
she told hosts Jimmy Fallon this
hilarious story about their little girl
Wyatt does she know that you're having a
baby at 21 once it's a little rough so I
could be like mommy's got a baby in her
belly and she's like and she has a
little baby and so she was like okay and
I'm like where's the baby
and then she'll pointer like my baby the
garbage man's belly like literally
anyone everywhere and so my husband
thought it was really funny so he taught
her if you go like where what's in
Papa's belly and he'll go beer
everyone's got a baby in their belly but
Papa's got beer actually but wait
there's more funny Ashton Wyatt moments
here's what Mila told the teen earlier
this month
bouncy roll and I was like oh my god I
love you so much